Speaker 1: You know, I love keeping you abreast
of different scams. And there has been no greater
scam in the COVID era than this. Urine drinker,
urine injector, urine nebulizer, Christopher Key.
If the name rings a bell, you may remember
that we covered this guy. Anti-vaxx leader
urges followers to drink their own urine to
fight COVID. That is not actually recommended.
Medically, you should not drink your own urine
to fight COVID. Anyway, he now says he invented
a hologram sticker where he stores information
and it has something to do with an energy field
and it can relieve pain if you put it in the
right spot. Now, here is my question about this.
Who is stupid enough to fall for this stuff.
And I know that it's very easy to say,
if you're dumb enough to fall for this, then you
deserve it. Right. A fool and their money are
soon parted, or whatever the case may be. But
it's hard for me to believe anyone with normal
cognitive function would fall for this. So then
I start to wonder, are the only people that fall
for this? Those who are cognitively limited and
actually do need to be protected from charlatans
like this? I don't know. Let's think about
that as we listen to what this guy explained.
Speaker 2: And I will send you this
page of chips out anywhere in the
world. And brother, I love it when it does it work
for somebody? Because then I want to go back to
the lab and try to figure out why God made you
different. This little chip is a hologram. We're
able to store information into the hologram, and
then we put in the energy field. It resonates.
And when I talk to some professors in Alabama
many years ago and they did the clinical study,
I was like, Christopher, how in the world
is this doing? This is not the by sticker,
guys. It's not just a sticker. It is
energy, it is frequencies. Everything
is frequency. Everything is there. Okay.
Speaker 1: So. I can't imagine there's a
single person in what I call my core audience.
Like, I get that there are people who watch from
all walks of life. But the people in my core
audience, people who like, subscribe to the
audio podcast and, you know, not maybe not every
episode, but like three times a week. You listen
to the show when you're at the gym or whatever
the case may be. I can't imagine there's a
single person in my audience that would fall for
this. And our audience at this point is sizable.
Where are the people that fall for this? Are they
of normal cognitive function? And if the answer is
no, then isn't what this guy is doing particularly
disgusting and particularly predatory? And of
course, I have the same questions that
often come up if he mentions God, if God
made you a little different than we just have
to tweak the sticker to get it to do the thing,
why wouldn't God just prevent you from needing the
sticker in the first place? Why wouldn't God just
cure your pain? Why isn't prayer enough? Why do
you need this guy's sticker with the energy field
and whatever the case may be? Now, when I look
at the sticker, I can tell you why the sticker
won't work. It doesn't have liquid silver in it,
of course. That's a joke. But that's the main
question I bring to you is who would actually fall
for this? I don't I know a lot of people who don't
have formal education. I know a lot of people that
I don't consider to be the smartest people. None
of them would fall for something like this or the
urine drinking. Who are the people that would? How
many of them are there? And quite frankly, do they
need to be protected from charlatans like this?